musique toujours on quitte le funk
c'était plutôt sympathique et oui et on
reste donc dans une page musicale nous
recevons ce soir yor bonsoir donc vous
êtes auteur compositeur interprète et
vous venez nous parler d'une méthode
originale d'apprentissage du français
pour les étrangers euh via donc une
plateforme en ligne alors expliquez-nous
le le concept oui en fait moi je suis
euh un tout nouvellement chanteur parce
que j'ai un un parcours un tout petit
peu euh bizarre puisque j'étais musicien
de jazz j'ai professeur aussi oui
professeur de français et de philo puis
comédien pendant des années et des
années je suis revenu avec des
circonstances un peu particulières
puisquon m'a annoncé que j'avais un
cancer du cerveau ce qui est faux c'est
une erreur euh et donc je me suis dit
qu'est-ce que j'ai envie de faire avant
de mourir j'ai décidé de refaire de la
musique mais alors théâtre d'un côté
philo français de l'autre musique ça a
donné le la chanson voilà et alors bon
ça fait fait 3 ans que que que je fais
ça et puis j'ai cherché évidemment bah à
développer mon art et mon métier dans
des des chemins un petit peu de traverse
et dans ces chemins de traverse
évidemment par l'enseignement j'en suis
venu à à côtoyer une une école qui
s'appelle Azurlingua à à Nice qui donc
apprend le le français aux étrangers
c'est le FLE le français langues
étrangères et ils ont une une une
plateforme qui est entièrement gratuite
et c'est ça que je trouve super où ils
apprennent o ils apprennent le français
aux étrangers alors il y a des tas de de
de d'exercices différents mais un des
exercice est une espèce de karaokeé
alors le terme peut faire
sourire disons que ça consiste à à ce
qu'il y ait en ligne des vidéos d'un
certain nombre de de chanteurs ces
vidéos les gens dans le monde entier
peuvent bah les écouter donc voir les
gens chanter entendre les paroles l les
paroles et à un moment donné ça s'arrête
et vous avez trois points de suspension
et vous devez voilà compléter la chanson
ne reprend qu'à partir du moment où ça a
été complété alors vous avez aussi un
petit clic qui permet de revenir 5
secondes en arrière et de réécouter
plusieurs fois le mot donc ça forge
l'oreille ben à la langue grâce à la à
la chanson franchement on l'a tous fait
moi je sais que les Beatles m'ont appris
le
l'anglais je trouve ça super que bah que
des chansons puissent faire apprendre la
langue française au aux étrangers et
donc c'est une plateforme qui
aujourd'hui présente également
différents clips différents alors sur la
plateforme effectivement nous sommes
plusieurs plusieurs artistes moi j'en
suis le parrain euh nous avons plusieurs
partenariats maintenant qui sont qui
sont faits
avec notamment les prestigie
prestigieuses éditions Raoul breton qui
sont à la base
les les éditions de de Charles
Trenet aujourd'hui ànavour bon et puis s
s verérino agè Bill encore malade et
cetera et cetera donc ils sont
partenaires de la de de la plateforme
nous avons francophane aussi qui est
donc ce ce ce magazine sur la chanson
française qui est qui est qui est qui
est là et donc sur la plateforme nous
avons différents ben anè Bill justement
à un clip qui est alors on va parler de
votre clip à vous on va écouter tout de
suite un extra et voir un extrait donc
du clip qui s'appelle poker un des clips
phar je crois sur votre page ce soir je
vais faire une petite partie de PO je te
J je vaâ je vais les gagner je vais les
éclater à cur je vais jeter j'attends
mon
untit instant je sens un FL et invisible
non non je jette c'est nul ne sois pas
[Musique]
bêteoule ma
vie non
su
pour tu
m'exaspèes je ne comprend pas pour poker
de York est avec nous ce soir pour le 78
et 7 page culture oui doncor dites-nous
la la queles sont les retombées j'irais
est-ce que vous avez une idée vous des
retombées de sur le site donc de de ces
téléchargement le les retour je vais
juste dire une petite chose c'est que
d'abord j'ai j'ai des amis qui qui sont
dedans et qui notamment le réalisateur
c'est Pierre touo et je voulais le le
CIT le nom CIT on s aussi auprès de lui
parce qu'on a dû couper for c'est un
tout petit extrait je sais que les
réalisateurs les les artistes n'aiment
pas la troupe ltistique avec yny et et
deux autres de de cette troup vous avez
une idée là des des retombées donc sur
le le site le nombre de personnes qui
qui vient cliquer
alors sur sur le sur le site lui-même
ils en sont à entre 25 et 30000 jours ah
oui sur le site d'accord sur les
chansons
euh évidemment beaucoup moins mais le le
site vous avez des tas d'exercices vous
avez un abécédaire vous avez un
conjugueur vous avez quelqu'un qui vous
corrige aussi la la prononciation enfin
c'est très très complet parce que l'idée
aussi sous-jacente c'est qu'ensuite ces
étrangers viennent en France oui oui
grâce à cette école oui oui oui dans le
dans dans l'école à sur lingua à à Nice
ce qui est extraordinaire c'est qu'on
véhicule à travers ça aussi tout ce qui
est la France par rapport aux étrangers
c'est-à-dire le pays des droits de
l'homme des libertés et c'est incroyable
d'ailleurs on est peut-être pas toujours
à la hauteur mais c'est incroyablece que
les étrangers peuvent avoir une idée
extraordinaire de la France et je trouve
ça super moi en tant que chanteur en
tout cas ce sont des valeur que j'aime
bien véhiculer bah d'être au service de
ça et d'être le Parin de ça juste pour
conclure malheureusement il nous reste
très peu de temps vos projets pour la
suite peut-être alors euh à la fin du
mois à
Marley je fais un concert dans un club
de de jazz je pars en Grèce à la fin du
mois d'avril parce qu'il y a une tournée
internationaleou une tournée
internationale tout à fait en Lituanie
en Grèce au Mexique au Brésil en Pologne
et cetera et cetera enfin bon c'est et
puis alors on est aussi partenaire avec
l'atelier d'en face qui est un un label
de de musique et je présente présente la
pochette
voil mon franais de C titres et qui est
donc qui sera prochainement disponible
via le via la plateforme oui la
plateforme est mon site yor.mu c'est
vrai que mon pays c'est le français je
me sens pas forcément français mais
c'est vrai que j'habite un mot j'habite
une langue donc mon pays c'est le
français merci AOR qui était donc
l'invité du 78 ce soir pour conclure
cette chronique culture Aurélia très
rapidement va falloir faire très très
vite quelqu dates dans
l'ENDA TR trois idées de sortie
culturelles pour ce weekend tout d'abord
pour les plus jeune vendredi 8 et samedi
9 à l'estaminé de Manil maniléamo pardon
une projection d'un film d'animation
pour les enfants à partir de 2 ans suivi
donc samedi au prisme d'élancour les
liaisons dangereuses seront adaptées
pour le théâtre et notons qu'il s'agit
d'une mise en scène de John malkovic et
enfin un dernière sortie pour les
solistes de la villedu qui seront donc
en représentation à l'auditorium de
l'école de musique à trpe Sam merci
Aurélia je vous l'ai dit c'est très
rapide si la régie est prête générique
merci je vous retrouve demain 18h
exercice pour la régie
[Musique]
he